marianne is in phoenix hi marianne
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and anthony um i'm calling i
have a
18 year old daughter who has 20 000
in the
yeah and we're trying to figure out
what's the best way for her to
use that money or where should she put
it besides just sitting in her bank
account
wow how did it get there that's my
question
well she has worked since she was 16 and
she just always saved her money
and then she had an unfortunate event
when her car got stolen
and she just got paid from the insurance
company
and so she has that money does she not
need a car
well we have a car that she can use so
we're not rushing her to purchase
another one
okay okay um how is she paying for
school
she has scholarships that pay for her
tuition her room and board okay and is
this
guaranteed and will it cover all four of
her years in school
correct okay and and then here's another
question what does she want to do after
school does she want to go
and pursue her master's at all
she does she would like to be a doctor
okay
and so that's why we don't know what she
should do
with that money i'm sure she's going to
need it yes i would just leave it
sitting right where it is right where it
is you put it in a money market account
if you want but it does not need to be
invested it doesn't need to be anything
fancy
it is for education yes okay
so it's fine to leave it in the checking
account yeah well i mean i might not
leave in a checking account just because
the temptation to spend it although this
kid is
very disciplined yeah and very curious
she is very difficult
i can tell i mean she's incredible she's
a she saved it up in the first place
um and you know you guys are obviously
coaching her well too
and and are speaking into her life in a
positive way that's all great
so yeah i mean i might move it over into
a money market account it might earn one
one and a half percent or something like
that it's not going to earn much
but the big thing is it gets it kind of
disconnected from the
day-to-day living of a checking account
which is always just a little tempting
and dangerous in that sense so
and marianne start having a conversation
now of where where she's thinking about
going
to school from med school and stuff like
that so that way
now you all can start saving and adding
more money to that account
so you already have a game plan on how
you're going to cash flow that
but that's the main thing from there